Today we will present bindary shield
cross service threat intelligence in LLM
services.
Uh little bit about ourself. I am war
skill and today I will uh we will be
presenting uh bindary shield and my
colleague is Natalia Sak. She is a
software engineering at Microsoft.
So let's uh jump to the problem. So many
organization has multiple services such
as for instance in case of Microsoft we
have uh Azure AI foundry GitHub copilot
and M3 co-i co c co c co c co c co c co
c co c co c co c co c co-pilot and these
services operate in a siloed way for
instance there is no information signal
from one service to another service so
and uh this makes the threat
intelligence between one service to
another service uh a very complicated
problem and
The problem is that the the data between
these services cannot be shared. So this
is the key key problem
and we need a cross service cross
service uh boundary thread correlation
uh that respects user privacy because we
cannot just share the raw prompt from
one service to another service and uh
the system at the same time also need to
be robust against minor perturbations
against such attacks like prompt
injection attacks.
And now if an adversary finds one
effective prompt transaction attack, it
can spread across all all of the
services of a of an organization.
So let's discuss how we can solve uh
this this problem. So here is the uh
let's say the highle architecture of
binary shield. So let's say we have an
attacker and attacker is sending the
prompt injection to uh similar prompt
transaction to multiple services. So for
instance in this case we have uh service
one service 2 service 3 and attacker is
is sending prompt p1 p2 p3 across all
these services and let's suppose uh the
service uh three is able to detect this
prompt uh that this is a prompt
injection attack and uh for and and each
prompt has two parts basically in terms
of threat correlation one is private uh
which which are the protected logs for
instance the user privacy uh user user
queries and the prompts those are the uh
that part of the uh the user query is
private and the other part other other
part is the metadata for instance region
of the query what tools are called uh
during uh execution of this query so in
the next step what bindary shield does
in the first step we remove the pi uh
personal identifiers for instance in the
query let's say if we have um uh uh uh
uh social security numbers or any any
any anything which is u uh personally uh
which can identify a person. So we
remove it and uh in the second step we
generate the embeddings from this pi
redacted text.
In the third uh step we do the
quantization which is basically we we
are project uh we are um uh we are
taking the embeddings and we are
converting into just uh 01 binary
quantization. And in the final step we
add the differential privacy with the by
the differential privacy means we
randomly flip bits uh from this uh uh
from the quantized embeddings to add
noise and uh in the final and then we
have we attach the system meta data such
as the uh how long this story uh takes
to execute uh the region of the query.
So those those are the parts in the in
this fingerprint which are related to
system metadata and finally we announce
it to the service one and uh service uh
two remember that the attack was
detected in uh P3. So in this way uh the
binary shield is able to correlate
threat from one service to another
service in a privacy preserving way.
Next uh a quick evaluation of the
results. Um so on the x-axis we have the
bindary shield privacy budget and on the
y-axis we have the accuracy the which is
the threat correlation accuracy and as
we can and uh the idea over here is that
the um as we decrease the privacy budget
we add more noise and the detection
accuracy goes to zero. For instance, uh
at roughly around
0.5, we have 0% uh accuracy which is due
to because we add uh we we flipped
almost all the bits uh in the quantizer
embings and as we increase the privacy
budget, we are adding less noise and we
we can see that the bindary shield
fingerprints are achieving the accuracy
closer to the denser embeddings. And um
so and here is another benefit of uh
using uh the binary shield that it's
significant faster as compared to uh
just using the uh uh the the floating
point embeddings. And uh on the x-axis
over here we have the uh uh cop size,
the data set size and the y-axis we have
the search time. And as we can see the
data set size is increasing. uh the the
search uh the dense embedding has a
significant overhead uh for for threat
correlation and at the same time the
binding shield h is uh 36x faster in
terms of threat correlation and uh so
the the key takeaway is that by binding
shield provides semantics speed privacy
and uh now I will hand over to my
colleague Nati she will walk through all
the steps in detail uh in her demo thank
you
>> awesome Awesome. Thanks, Wares. Uh, so
before I dive straight into the code,
uh, just to kind of summarize what Wars
went through, uh, we really need the
ability to correlate related prompt
injections through unrelated products or
services without revealing any customer
content. So that's kind of the goal. Um,
Wars kind of walk through like the what,
so what it is. Um, and in this next
part, uh, when it loads,
um, I'll give it a second. Um, I'm going
to walk through a demo of how you
actually implement these, some of the
trade-offs and choices you make when
implementing this. Um, and then also
using these fingerprints, how you might
apply that to your product suite. Um,
one second.
Why this is
okay? Great. So, like I mentioned uh in
act one, we're going to actually build
the fingerprint. So, the four-step
sequence uh that Warus described, and
we're going to go step by step what this
means.
So the first step is to remove all
personally identifiable information from
the prompt. So in this example here we
have my name is John Smith. We strip
that name away and we replace it with
kind of a holder. We do that for all
things like social security numbers,
emails, etc. And we just redact all of
that information. So that's the first
step of the pipeline.
We uh just to kind of call this out in
our implementation we use a open- source
library called Procedto. Uh but there
are many different ways uh to do this.
The next step is we translate uh these
strings these words into embeddings. So
vectors that capture the semantic
meaning uh in long lists of numbers. So
we take this redacted prompt, we feed it
into an embedding model. We used uh text
embedding three large from open AAI. Um
but to reduce cost there are many
different implementations of this. Um
and in the output we get long lists of
floatingoint numbers.
Um the next step the third step is to
quantize it. So what we're doing here is
we're compressing this long list of uh
long floatingoint numbers into just
zeros and ones. So we're reducing the
amount of memory it takes up which leads
to efficiency gains and it also uh makes
the the pipeline more one way. So we're
intentionally losing information that's
kind of encapsulated by these long
floatingoint numbers to make it more
difficult for an adversary to reverse
engineer this pipeline and ultimately
gain any private information from the
users.
And then the last step is uh adding
differential privacy and essentially
injecting noise into this list of
integers. So what this means it's
controlled by this value called epsil
epsilon. And when epsilon is large the
bits don't change. So that means that
there's very little privacy but high
utility. And then the inverse is also
true. When epsilon is small the bits are
more random. So there's a lot of privacy
but very little utility.
And just to double click here, epsilon
should be kind of a function of your
organization. We don't particularly make
a recommendation of what epsilon should
be, but rather it should be kind of
contingent on your own use case, how
compliant uh the data is that you're
working with um and kind of a close
collaboration with your legal teams to
understand um what level of privacy you
need to attain before you can look at
these fingerprints and share them in a
safe manner.
Um, and then all I'm doing here, um, is
stringing together those four steps. So,
we're creating the fingerprint. I'm just
going to go a little faster. Um, and
then just to make it super concrete, um,
I've created a list of four prompts. So,
we have three kind of variations of the
canonical ignore all system instruction
prompt, uh, which we call like a prompt
injection. and it could potentially
override uh the intended behavior of
your system. And then one benign prompt.
So what is the weather in Seattle? It's
not something that we would assume to be
um malicious and is very different from
those three prompts.
Um so I'm going to kind of show a matrix
here. Um, and what I'm trying to
demonstrate here is that prompts that
are similar
are ultimately more similar
fingerprints. So, if this system is to
work, we want to be able to correlate
related prompts that are very very
similar, i.e. uh capture maybe like a
spray attack of related prompt
injections and we don't want to catch
like benign prompts or things that are
very dissimilar. So to walk through this
diagram, uh the original uh variant one
and variant two were all of those
related prompts of ignore all system
instructions. And you can see that the
we call it hamming distance like the
distance between these fingerprints
um is much lower. So it's like a lighter
color. Whereas the difference between
the benign prompts and the original
variant one variant two this lower row
and this um the row the column to the
right hand side uh they have much higher
distances. So the fingerprints are
farther away. So it's easier to
understand that they're different.
Um so that's the how like that's how you
might create a fingerprint. Um, and the
last kind of step that I want to walk
through is what it actually means to
integrate this into your product suite.
So, to just give like a brief overview
first, um, for any sort of company or
organization that has more than one
product, um, it's very likely that your
safety stack is going to start to
diverge. So ultimately it would be great
if as security and safety practitioners
all of the products had all of the best
practices and all look the same. But
unfortunately given uh like dev velocity
um and different customer requirements,
different regulatory requirements,
different regions you're deploying in.
It's very likely that as an organization
you're going to end up with a very messy
situation very quickly where you have
many products with different safety
stacks. And if a attack is caught by one
product, it might not be caught by all
products. So this is kind of what we're
trying to solve here.
Um we implement a couple things. One is
a registry which Warus kind of talked
about. And the key thing here is that we
publish fingerprints. So if we identify
a attack, we're going to fingerprint it
and we're going to broadcast it to all
of the services. So all services will
now be able to catch that same attack.
So if an adversary has one prompt
injection that's very effective or small
perturbations that are very effective of
that one prompt injection and it sprays
it against your entire suite with this
registry, you should be able to
effectively publish.
Um and then to kind of demonstrate this
point, I've created three different
services. Um so here to demonstrate that
idea of like we have different safety
stacks each service alpha beta and gamma
they have different block lists.
Hopefully in your production systems you
have more sophisticated uh ways of
catching malicious activity. Um but to
kind of like make it very succinct we
have three different block lists for
three different services and they catch
different things. So uh the first
service alpha is able to catch the
pattern ignore all previous instructions
but service gamma is not able to.
Um and to tie this all together um I'm
just going to open up just like some
print statements. Um so what I did here
is I fed all four prompts remember those
um original the two variants and then
the benign through all three services.
Um, and only in service alpha was I
actually able to catch that ignore all
system instructions. So what's supposed
to happen here is then service alpha
fingerprints that prompt and it
broadcasts to service beta and gamma and
now all services are able to catch that
same variant of prompt injections. So
the next time that the adversary kind of
sprays that attack, now all of the
services have that same capability of
catching the attack without having to
rehaul their entire safety stacks.
I think that is time and that's all I
have. Um, we're happy to answer any
questions. Now,
uh, I have a Slack question about
whether the components of this are going
to be open sourced. So I'll start there.
So uh right now the paper is available.
Um it didn't take me too long to make
the notebook with cloud code. So I would
uh start there but we are uh we we can
definitely look into open sourcing this.
>> Cool. Uh mic on mic on its way.
>> When you are quanti quantizing your
embeddings you are converting them to
zeros and ones. It seems you are losing
a lot of semantics there. Um how do you
address that? And on your privacy budget
side, every time you create a
fingerprint, you are consuming some of
your privacy budget. How do you refresh
that?
>> Okay. Uh great question. So first to
answer your question, so this is um
definitely we are losing semantics. But
for instance, if you say uh if you see
that the embeddings are usually like
they have a high dimensions for instance
768 dimension or let's say uh 30s 84 or
something like that for text open
embedding model. So there is a lot of
information which is encoded into 01
information. Even still if we let's say
convert it into 0 and one. So there is
still lot of semantic information which
is very useful for detecting attacks and
that what we uh observed in our
evaluations. So we have um and the to to
your point to u uh the privacy budget uh
that is we also vary it and then we see
for instance the utility for instance if
we uh flip so many bits the utility will
go down to zero. So definitely like uh
there is a trade-off uh we if we consume
uh uh less budget uh let's say if we
have a lower privacy budget we will be
adding more noise and uh this is a
trade-off uh which we have observed and
that's what Natly mentioned that we do
not uh specify any particular budget for
this threat correlation uh and it
depends uh on the organization they can
work with their privacy teams to uh
basically uh come up with that
particular epsilon number uh for the
noise.
>> Uh great talk and I have a question. So
I feel like right now you're just like
catching the prompt uh um um like um one
by one like whack-a-ole. I was wondering
if there's if it's possible once we we
find you find like a prompt that's u um
like evil and you can like generate
variants using large models and then so
you can like put them in the registry.
Uh so instead of like having to catch
them one by one, you can like generate
variance and like prevent them uh ahead
of the time.
>> Yeah, I have a couple thoughts there. So
the point of uh the fingerprint being
fuzzy also like remember in the demo I
created two variants of the same prompt.
Yes, you can and should definitely
generate your own synthetic data, but
ultimately this technique uh captures
like a ring around the original prompts.
It would catch small perturbations that
you would end up getting from that like
whack-a-ole situation, if that makes
sense. So, we're not catching um
verbatim prompts one by one. We're
capturing the prompt you want to catch
and then small perturbations as well.
And you can kind of adjust your
threshold as needed if you want to kind
of catch a wider range.
Thanks very much. Awesome.